[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
lundi 20 décembre voici les titres de
cette édition
25 millions de français éligibles à la
dose de rappel vaccinal face à la
cinquième bague et l'appel de la
troisième dose de plusieurs centres de
vaccination ont repris du service dans
les yvelines le point sur la vaccination
dans ce journal depuis trois mois le
collège debussy à saint germain les nous
accueille autour du projet élèves
tombent loeb une exploration
pluridisciplinaire pour ce troisième
volet le blob a permis aux élèves de
développer leur imaginaire et puis à
poissy c'est un peu noël avant l'heure
la traditionnelle grande parade a
déambulé dans les rues du centre ville
au programme chars fanfares ou encore
acrobates retour sur l'édition 2021 dans
ce journal
[Musique]
et pour les fêtes de fin d'année
l'établissement français du sang appelle
à une mobilisation générale pour le don
de sang le faith alerte sur les faibles
réserves notamment 85000 poche
disponible contre 115 mille nécessaire
en cette période ça ce pour couvrir les
besoins de cette période justement à
savoir que si le pass sanitaire n'est
pas obligatoire pour donner son sang des
mesures bien évidemment de précaution
ont été mises en place pour éviter lé
risque de propagation de la cosi 19 lors
des collectes plus d'informations sur le
site de le ffs ou sur l'application don
de sang
et puis politologue professeur de
sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin cofondateur
également du printemps républicain un
mouvement qui défend une conception
forte de la laïcité laurent bouvet est
mort ce samedi des suites de la maladie
de charcot il avait 53 ans après des
études de sociologie politique une thèse
dirigée par pierre rosanvallon est une
agrégation de sciences politiques
laurent bouvet souriante à la fois vers
l'enseignement et l'engagement proche du
ps notamment et créé le concept
d'insécurité culturel qui lui vaudra ses
premiers démêlés avec une certaine
gauche mais c'est après les attentats de
2015 et la création du printemps
républicain qui défend une conception
stricte de la laïcité que ce clivage
apparaîtra plus clairement encore
laissant place à ce que manuel valls
appelé de gauche inconciliables au
lendemain de sa mort l'elysée a salué un
des hellions les plus vifs au paysage
intellectuel français et le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer reluit et explique l'homme qui
est défendez ce que nous avons de plus
précieux la république et donc la
liberté
le hameau c'est un nouveau complexe
hôtelier qui verra le jour d'ici 2023 à
poissy l'objectif du projet permettre
aux habitants en franciliens d'avoir un
pied à terre dans la région entre
maisons de campagne et et hôtels de luxe
jeudi 16 décembre dernier c'est le
premier arbre qui était planté comme
symbole d'un lieu qui se veut aussi
proche de la nature le reportage de
bixente mais rien senti steben à
l'emplacement de l'ancienne ferme du
pouls à poissy naîtra d'ici 2023 l'hôtel
le hameau 82 chambres deux piscines un
spa deux restaurants et un projet éco
durables jeudi 16 décembre dernier il
est entré dans une nouvelle phase avec
la plantation du premier arbre on
souhaite voir proposer aux gens quelque
chose un petit peu différente que ce
qu'on peut se connaît dans l'hôtellerie
traditionnelle avec cet esprit maison de
vacances en effet où le week-end l'idée
c'est de venir de prendre d'avoir une
paire de bottes à disposition un anorak
de pouvoir se balader en famille de
déguster les bons petits plats de passer
un moment agréable autour de la cheminée
le projet est de par sa nature
complètement écocentres et dans la
proche on est dans un projet où on
souhaite accueillir les gens déjà dans
un cadre très naturel autour de l'hôtel
un grand terrain agricole est un art un
dédié aux sports équestres
professionnels et amateurs et à
l'élevage
c'est pas un club privé c'est un c'est
un hôtel près d'un rat ouvert à tout le
monde et voilà et je pense qu'il faut en
faire un lieu convivial show chaleureux
pour les gens qui sont amoureux des
chevaux situé à deux pas du futur centre
d'entraînement du paris saint germain
c'est un nouveau lieu d'activités pour
la commune pisciacaise ici on est sur
des terres
agricole historique on est sur des
espaces céréaliers on est sur une
bâtisse qui est séculaire et c'est
important de poursuivre cette activité
qui va mais là la fois le développement
économique et préserver effectivement
tout ce qui concerne le défi de
l'environnement durable l'implantation
d'un premier arbre comme promesse et
symboles au total 6000 arbres vont être
répartis sur les 15 hectares de terrains
du complexe hôtelier
[Musique]
et je vous le disais en titre face à la
cinquième vague de l'épidémie de quoi
vivent 19 l'ouverture de la dose de
rappel à tous les plus de 18 ans
également plusieurs centres de
vaccination ont repris du service dans
les yvelines ont fait le point dans ce
journal sur la vaccination et c'est avec
vous marion est une alliée bonjour
bonjour je rappelle à vous êtes à
directrice de la délégation yvelines
pour la grèce ile de france et vous avez
déjà reçu il ya un peu moins d'un mois
en plateau justement à l'annonce de
cette cinquième vague est ce qu'on peut
faire le point aujourd'hui on en est en
termes de chiffres le pic n'a pas encore
été atteint
non effectivement on est dans une
situation qui est vraiment inquiétante
et qui se dégrade très vite là depuis
les derniers jours on a eu un taux
d'incidence régionale qui est à 100 6
124 cas pour 100000 habitants il est à
536 au niveau national donc vraiment
l'île de france commence à décrocher au
niveau des yvelines à vendredi on était
à 4 165 cas pour 100000 habitants en
termes d'incidence et en taux de
positivité on est à 6 4% donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de dépistage il ya
plus d'un million 4 dépistage par
semaine qui sont réalisés au niveau
francilien donc ça explique aussi cette
tendance à la hausse des chiffres mais
ça n'explique pas tout en fait on
comprend que par ce nom de cas de
contamination quotidien qui ne cesse
d'augmenter on a la part du variant au
micro qui est beaucoup plus présente que
ce qu'on imaginait au niveau de la
population générale donc une alerte 1 il
faut continuer à être prudents et ça
respecte et je rigole ailleurs mais
malgré la vaccination
exactement port du masque lavage de
mains aération vraiment il faut il faut
y aller aujourd'hui au micro au micro
par don représente entre
peu près 25% de la part des dépistages
positifs en ile de france et donc nous
notre notre arme la meilleure on est
pour le moment c'est vraiment le rappel
vaccinal
avec les périodes de fin d'année sont
plus favorables au rapprochement
finalement que ce soit familial ou avec
l'entourage donc il faut continuer à
être prudents vous le disiez dans les
yvelines pour revenir sur les centres il
ya huit centres de vaccination enfin 8
une dizaine de centres de vaccination
qui ont repris du service on est assez
centre aujourd'hui contre 18 lors de la
précédente campagne mais finalement plus
de professionnels de santé qu'ils
vaccinent donc finalement est-ce que ça
s'équilibre
ah oui ça c'est ça s'équilibre
parfaitement bien dans les yvelines à
plus de 90% de nos pharmaciens qui
vaccinent on a énormément professionnels
de santé qui vaccinent également jusqu'à
ce qu'on relance les centres de
vaccination enfin que miles bien le
territoire c'était la ville qui avaient
la part la plus importante de
vaccination dans le département
évidemment là puisqu'on a relancé dix
centres supplémentaires et qu'on a
atteint les 16 la part des centres de
vaccination est un peu supérieure à
celle de la ville mais enfin vraiment la
ville est extrêmement mobilisés
aujourd'hui
si je vous parle de samedi soir sur
toute la semaine au niveau régional à
samedi soir on avait fait 8 146 mille
injection dans toute l'ile-de-france
avec 54% des vaccinations qui sont
faites ensemble de vax et les 46 autres
vraiment au niveau de la ville donc la
ville participe très activement et il ya
un vrai maillage territorial et on le
voit également sur les yvelines est ce
que vous vous conseiller par exemple de
plus se tourner justement vers ces
professionnels de santé infirmiers ou
encore vers les pharmaciens pour cette
dose de rappel ou peu importe finalement
je peux importe en fait il faut aller là
où il ya de la place après c'est en
fonction aussi de la disponibilité de
chacun de la proximité et du temps de
déplacement qu'on peut qu'on peut mettre
donc il n'y a aucune difficulté à l'eswc
un ensemble de vaccination soit soit
chez sont chez son pharmacien ou chez
son médecin ou auprès d'un infirmier il
n'y a vraiment pas de pas de souci
là-dessus
pour continuer un peu peut-être pour
faire un point sur les chiffres dont
département on a un peu plus de 90% des
yvelinois qui avaient leur schéma
vaccinal au complet en tout cas avant
cette dose de rappel aujourd'hui on a un
peu plus de 380 mille personnes qui ont
reçu cette dose de rappel mais
finalement il reste peu de temps avant
finalement l'échéance du 15 janvier où
les passionnés terre vont être entre
guillemets annulé en attente de cette
troisième dose est ce qu'on arrivera à
vacciner tout le monde est ce qu'il
faudra prendre son mal en patience
comment ça se passe mais on en est
aujourd'hui février arriver parce qu'on
fait plus de 90000 injection par semaine
dans les yvelines et encore une fois la
durant les congés scolaires des centres
de vaccination et les professionnels de
ville vont faire en sorte d'ouvrir des
créneaux des créneaux sont même déjà
ouvert donc on va même pas perdre malgré
les vacances scolaires on va pas perdre
je pense en volume d'injection on a 80 2
% de nos plus de 65 ans qui ont eu une
dose de rappel donc ça c'est quand même
très bien et il faut vraiment engagé
tout le monde à aller faire cette dose
de rappel et ceux qui n'ont pas eu de
vaccination a même démarré une primo
injection
pour vraiment se protéger contre cette
cinquième vague là qui bat son plein et
pour laquelle on n'a pas à atteindre
c'est très important de rappeler qu'il
est toujours possible en effet de faire
cette première dose on va peut-être
faire un point sur l'opération maximus
qui a été relancée finalement sont donc
des bus qui sillonnent un peu le
département pour rendre accessible cette
vaccination cette fois ils sont au
nombre de trois est ce que c'est une
opération qui est essentiel finalement
oui tout à fait c'est le conseil
départemental avec lequel on avait mis
ça en place lors de la première campagne
de vaccination ont la réactiver la en
novembre effectivement le conseil
départemental a pu mobiliser encore plus
sa flotte de bus avec donc des bus
supplémentaires 3 qui tourne dans les
quartiers et dans les zones rurales donc
en fait il ya un système de réservation
avec les collectivités qui sont
intéressés et puis le conseil
départemental pour pouvoir aller au plus
près des personnes qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner et pour manier
correctement le territoire et ça ça
vient compléter ce qu'on fait également
dans les opérations ce qu'on appelle
d'aller vers à la fois vers des publics
qui sont éloignés du soin dans des
centres d'hébergement des choses comme
ça on fait ça avec des équipes dédiées
et puis à la fois des opérations
exceptionnelles qui sont portés par des
collectivités sur un de week end on en a
fait par exemple à feucherolles a loupé
sienne il y en a créé pierre fa voilà il
ya différentes communes qui sont
intéressés qui offre cette possibilité à
leurs populations
merci beaucoup mariachis thani d'avoir
été avec nous pour ce point sur la
vaccination je le rappelle vous êtes
directrice de la délégation yvin pour
les ré île de france merci
[Musique]
et on va maintenant prendre la direction
de saint germain en laye ce vendredi 17
décembre un nouveau un nouveau centre
direct europe direct a été inauguré à
dans la commune c'est est au sein de la
maison de l'europe ce service
d'informations générales permet de
répondre à des questions de rencontrer
des experts et d'échanger sur l'union
européenne pour l'occasion à une plaque
a été dévoilée devant la structure les
réactions au micro de nos confrères de
radio sensations avec michael et meadow
c'est un lien très important et c'est un
lien qu'il faut promouvoir au quotidien
la maison de l'europe die linke j'ai
l'honneur de présider fait cela fait
cela au quotidien vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de nos administrés dans nos
territoires yvelinois parce que l'europe
est très présent beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne le savent pas mais
l'europe est déjà très présente et il
est important que l'on puisse promouvoir
et valoriser tout ce que l'europe fait
depuis trois mois le collège debussy à
saint germain en laye et nous accueille
lors d'un ton de l'enseignement autour
d'un seul et même thème le blob c'est un
organisme ni animal ni végétales et qui
est sujet de nombreuses études notamment
une menée par thomas pesquet dont les ss
si le spationaute lui est de retour sur
terre depuis bien longtemps et bien
l'établissement continue de travailler
sur cette thématique et pour ce mois de
décembre c'est anna jours d'un
professeur de français et ses élèves qui
ont reçu mélanie poker regardez vous
avez fait des expériences svt vous avez
fait des calculs en physique chimie vous
avez exploité votre travail en arts
plastiques
dahmane ancien nous de reprendre le blog
après le travail des mains le travail
des mots au collège debussy de saint
germain en laye le blob inspire les
jeunes et les professeurs les élèves de
nageurs d'un développent leur imaginaire
et leur capacité à s'exprimer dans la
tendance du moment en fait à considérer
que les élèves écrivent beaucoup mais
qu'on met un peu de côté la place de
l'oral ils sont très angoissés des
queues on leur demande de passer et
j'arrive on va essayer de faire deux
étapes vous allez être capable de
présenter un projet que vous allez
imaginé en groupe et puis après on va
passer à l'écrit quatre heures
d'enseignement par semaine et des
échanges personnels science fiction
horreur slam ou encore journal intime ce
travail met à profit toutes les qualités
qui nous intéressait dans l'association
c'est que on pouvait qu on pouvait se
projeter dans l'avenir et imaginer et ça
nous a aussi permis dérivés sur
l'horreur un petit peu que ça permet
vraiment à tout le monde de pouvoir
s'exprimer dans ce qu'il est le plus à
l'aise pour moi ça va être pas le dessin
d'autre part la musique ça permet
vraiment hâte de pouvoir s'exprimer
comme ils voudraient de pas être mal à
l'aise l'établissement saint germanois
continue son exploration
pluridisciplinaire dans le projet élèves
tombent loeb les élèves vont continuer à
travailler sur leur production jusqu'au
mois de mai le collège debussy tondre
alors la page de l'expérience autour des
blobs
du football à présent est une bonne
nouvelle versailles qui évolue en
nationale 2 s'est qualifié pour les
seizièmes de finale de la coupe de
france c'était ce samedi les joueurs de
la cité royale se sont imposés 1 but à 0
en terre alsacienne c'était face à sarre
union union par dont le but a été
inscrit par djoko capitte en première
période et versailles et affronteront au
prochain tour un autre club de national
troyes la roche sur yon objectif
dépasser le meilleur parcours de
l'histoire du club qui étaient 1 1 16e
de finale en 1948 on écoute le capitaine
de l'équipe au micro de michael vidéo là
je pense qu'avec le tirage ça reste à sa
reste un match abordable maintenant on
va bien préparer ce match on sait que
que cette équipe de la revente est une
très bonne équipe qui est invaincue
cette année qui est deuxième avec un
point de retard
avec deux matches en moins
donc on sait que ce sera pas facile et
de toutes les manières tous les matches
que nous avons fait jusqu'à présent
coupe de france en a aucun qui ait été
facile
et pour terminer cette édition la
traditionnelle parade de noël à poissy a
fait son grand retour après une édition
précédente impacté par l'aco vide au
total ce sont 19 chars qui ont défilé ce
samedi à 18 décembre partie de l'hôtel
de ville la parade a parcouru les rues
du centre ville sous les
applaudissements de nombreux habitants
c'est d'une charles était sur place
regardez c'est un peu noël avant l'heure
sur leurs traîneaux le père noël et le
maire de la ville ouvre le bal chars
décorés fanfare mascotte de dessins
animés ou encore acrobates ont
transformé le centre ville de poissy en
une grande fête féerique un succès qui
fait du bien même si les masques étaient
également de la partie les gens sont
très heureux de se retrouver la france a
besoin de cela et on le voit bien depuis
le début de la journée ici au village de
noël c'est un relais incessant de gens
qui sourient et on avait encore une fois
perdu l'habitude et moi ça me fait
plaisir de voir les pisciacaise et les
pisciacais sourire ce sont plus de 200
personnes la plupart bénévoles qui ont
défilé sous un ciel clair un clin d'oeil
cette année pour la russie on est ici
sur la place rouge la place rouge acquis
qui inondent la place de la république
la place rouge parce que la ville de
poissy va être jumelée avec une ville
moscovite une ville russe qui s'appelle
kalouga et donc on a décidé de faire un
clin d'oeil à nos amis russes comme on
l'avait fait que nos amis allemands non
nés en compagnie russe donc elle a tenu
très belle russe
cette présentation la russie et on danse
moi je suis
dans cette pratique pourrait avoir
quelques noms ces acrobates rousset j'ai
mon but
et tout le monde a joué le jeu quand on
peut finalement être dans l'habit de
lumière et dans l'habit du père noël
pour faire sourire les gens je me pose
pas de questions et je suis très heureux
parce que j'ai l'impression que les
pisciacais et les pisciacais s'en posent
pas également la parade de noël à moitié
elle est vraiment très connue est
phénoménal
[Musique]
un rendez vous qui comme chaque année a
su faire briller les yeux des habitants
en attendant les fêtes
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivis très bonne soirée
sur tv 78 et prenez soin de vous
[Musique]